I was just reading a post on Facebook
now long time ago and it was a profound
statement a sister made which I just
found interesting she was like I would
rather spend half the time with a good
man than full time with a wasteman I
[Music]
said I'm awakened when I mentally better
care to buffers and citizen dear friends
welcome to another episode of talk to me
I'm your host a leader on the show
before I start I want to introduce our
dear
there was advocate what is the main line
actually as priority what's your role on
this show a key okay so I can so that
role is to essentially contest the main
arguments and try and show the the other
side of the argument yes exciting
and on your left is Baba listen and here
we have brother Mohammed hijab who's
involved in the Dawa and he's a youtuber
himself and what brother Asif yep okay
so today's topic is something
controversial someone was get excited in
the Ariat sisters get angry it's the
matter of polygamy the question that
needs to be asked is is polygamy
something that could be practiced in
today's time brother Mohammed what's
your take on this do you think it can be
practiced do you think maybe men take
advantage of this you know expand a bit
well definitely men do take advantage of
this just as they do take advantage of
many things because as the Quran says in
the Lantana layout Oh father surely man
is in a state of transgression and that
applies to men and women but generally
speaking going back to what you said
which is absolutely true I think it's
very important to note that in all of
the ancient texts almost without any
exception like for example the Old
Testament you have Abraham has three who
has three we have two wives with one
concubine Solomon has 300 wives and 700
concubines in in in other texts like for
example even the six scriptures
six
of six of the 12 jurors were in
polygamous relationship so this is not
an exclusive like Islam doesn't have the
monopoly of on this and as you correctly
said as well like for example liberalism
as a political philosophy doesn't
doesn't actually restrict people from if
they wanting if they wanted to practice
polygamy and this goes for both genders
birth birth support failed me I would
say on the other side of the argument is
I mean we're living in a country where
polygamy marriage is committed it's
illegal Muslims be instructed if I
should have paid it and the law of the
land and although it is permissible in
Sainik Lord is nothing in Islamic law
that has made it mandatory of choice to
go our way to have polygamous marriage
so therefore when you're looking at two
sides of the coin where one is legal
stance on the country that you're living
in to something where it's just merely
you know should this take our food we
should escape correct it is illegal but
then that begs the question why is
polygamy illegal per se an adultery is
not illegal I mean this is an incredible
double standard or moral perspective
very very valid question I just want to
do like a little survey here how me okay
let's come to the Bombers how many of
you guys would get into a polygamous
marriage do you understand where the
cameras are on you you know how many of
you guys would get into a polygamous
marriage for example not in this let's
say if he was in a country that's legal
for example one two three four sisters
how many of you guys wouldn't have a
problem with your husband marrying again
yes that was expected okay once it's
okay so what I'm gonna do is I'm gonna
come to the sisters sisters what is your
main concerns with the issue of polygamy
not that you're against it obviously
but what's a--what's you're sailing it's
like let's go to some sisters like what
is what is the fears maybe sisters face
or what is it that we wouldn't take it
from your point of view let's go to the
sister shop yeah yeah it's all about
honesty if you're gonna get into it then
you should be honest and upfront before
you marry someone because that girl
might not know what she's getting
herself into you and why I've seen from
like I love older people is that they're
like go hide a second my somewhere and
though they wouldn't really tell them
and somehow they'll all find out and
then the kids will get involved and then
the kids also have some sort of like
hatred towards their parent and that's
not nice so you're saying it shouldn't
be hidden you know the only problem is
when they make them they make a problem
when they when the wife thinks that he's
done it behind her back or or something
like that that's when it becomes a
problem there's no problem I do disagree
with one of the sisters that said that
it should be you should not be hidden
before you care because you know as the
law of the quranic fitrah a man might
not decide at the point of Naqada first
iike that he's not going to a second one
oh it's not going to involve himself in
another marriage but later during the
course of the same car he might decide
that I want to go to ganger in a
marriage okay so one says that it should
not be as it should be revealed before
in the car because that's not always a
choice and that's not always the case is
sometimes even for example if a man said
okay very liberal and said yes I don't
mind getting into you into tuna cars or
you know how much Islam premises to and
then if he declares that in the society
we're living in the first thing that the
girl or you know the the the other the
opposite gender will say okay sorry
sorry I'm a can't be revealed so then
becomes hard for the man as well even
though he's according to the Sharia okay
and what's too much shouldn't he be open
if she says he wants to get married
again he shouldn't he be vocal open
about that to his first wife that I will
do this that's what the sisters trying
to say like you should be open about it
before me yeah before marriage so that's
one
always the case because you see in the
brothel map say you know what no I don't
wanna get married again but later on he
might change his mind
yeah but then again we do have a ruling
but it's called say for example that if
you know if the wife says I you know she
does get married again and it's signed
it might be too late for you to change
your mind because it's done and dusted
which the citizen might rejoice at this
they don't know how however the question
is one of yes many a times or what
usually boils down to when accosted to
permissibility of it is that whether the
husband's can be fair or it can be equal
and there will be some argue against is
that well in this day and age no it
can't be especially in the West and in
this country their standard of living is
getting higher many people can't afford
to take on the second wife usually
you'll find ones that do engage in that
as well they all end up cheating the
system by trying to do something that's
allowed but then again something again
which is going against the law of the
land
okay as a person who lives in Britain
yeah you said about the it's not obeying
the law of the land the law of the land
doesn't recognize any car anyway so hon
us my marriage is Nicole only I haven't
gone to any ok-ish law and got it signed
up my Anika is only in a car it's not a
British marriage so they don't have
recognized my marriage anyway no smoking
sign but you getting married again no no
no no cuz my car's not recognized so
it's not even a marriage I'm involved in
the guys not recognized by a Brit in a
we're not talking about here is it valid
or not was seen as a man yes I'm not
breaking the law and I would do it
because hopefully is that the only
reason that is halal is in allah says
take two three or four you don't say
take one first he says and then an ayah
two or three ayahs down the road allah
says and you will never be just so fair
long you will always love maybe the
sisters want to finish the ir
you know we said to freeze and forth she
says is that where the AIA ends there's
this is that where it ends
let's go to the sister here you can't be
just say that if you have a fear that
you cannot be just yeah then you take
one yeah well I let the sister finish it
for you
it's not possible okay so okay let me
ask a question can we say how love is
not something that you can control goes
to your heart he's spoken about this he
says volantis tortilla and Tantillo
brain and a hollow hollow stone if I let
you cool it Milford after work and
Molokai says that you will never be able
to be just with your wives and even if
you're try it so that he gives you
advice he says so don't so don't lean
literally that requires question mister
English so don't lean in one direction
of one woman so to leave the other ones
to spend another word is basically that
when it comes to you where your heart is
right held the counter in regards to
what we've seen in many statistics yeah
well love is that take on another wife
what happens is that end up cheating the
system right those little claims single
for the second benefit do around the
bend things to try and get something
which then that's not right no matter
and using you both of you in the video
and you were saying that Britain people
in Britain practice polygamy but they
don't see it as polygamy
mm-hmm so boyfriends and girlfriends
having having more people have more
important that is that is polygamy but
they won't see it because of yeah cuz
the way they see polygamy or when they
think bringing all more than one life no
we don't really but then but then
technically they're doing it already
okay so the question that need to be
asked is okay look if we look at maybe
certain individuals they have a right to
you know premarital relationships
girlfriends etc so what's the difference
because if we look at it we can say you
know they actually practicing polygamy
but with no rules or regulations so you
know maybe maybe somebody might come and
say in Islam there's rules and
regulations to protect the woman but
over here maybe there's individuals who
go out there and just you know have
girlfriends 2 3 4 5 6 7 whatever it may
be so what's what's your take on this
let's go to this sister and then we'll
go here because it's not legalized it's
not written on paper yes that's the
difference that's where they can it can
be with multiple partners yeah but in
this time we don't we don't have that
you know you know not to be with another
person until you're married okay that's
the difference okay so this okay so
let's go to the system genre yeah and
point I wanted to make was more on a
sense of if you look at the reasons
polygamy happens in you know Islamic
history and in our culture's it's not
because of lust if you look at for
example in my country the living
standards are quite bad so if you if a
man passes away his brother will marry
the wife and these are reasons that you
know you can father make sense but in
the sense of okay I'm living in the West
and I have desires you know you
shouldn't even be looking at a woman
that's not your wife